ドンドンドン
ドーンキー
ドン・キーホーテ
よーなかは
ヤンキーぞくぞくわくわく～
う~~ ヤンキーだー
ドンドン　あ～ちょっとやめよう
ヤンキーに怒られる
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
はい。と言う訳で今は夜中の3時なんですけども
夜中の僕の楽しみです。
買い物に行ってこようと思います。
が
ただのお買い物をしても面白くないと思ったので、
ちょっと変わった方法でお買い物しようかなと思っております。
その方法は
ドン・キホーテ
目隠し買い物
やってみたぁ～
僕が今から後輩を連れて、ドンキホーテに買い物に行きます。
そのドンキーホーテで買い物をする時に僕は、目隠しをして買い物をします。
もちろん危ないので後輩を一人つかせて一緒に行くんですけども
後輩がサポート、で僕はもう目隠しでドンキーをこうグルグル回ると
ドンキってね物がめちゃくちゃ多いんすよ。
凄い数の物があるのでホントに訳分かんない物が、たくさんあるので
僕はその、訳が分かんない位たくさんの量なる物の中で
何を目隠しをして選ぶのか
ドンキの中でランダムで「ポ」っと、こう買うとしたら
何が手に入るのかって言うのをちょっとね実験したくなったので
後輩が僕をちょっと誘導してくれつつ、目隠しでドンキで買い物していきます。
果たして何が手に入るのか楽しみですね。
では、早速ドンキに行ってみましょう。
なんでこれ目光ってんの
じゃあ、ここから出てきたらいいの
え
え、俺のせいじゃないよ
はい。と言う訳でやってまいりました。ドンキ・ホーテでございます。
何が欲しい。狙いに行くとしたら。
普通っけどティッシュは欲しい。パーティーグッズ。
パーティーグッズ
そこらへん狙っていきたいですね。
ちょっと早速買い物行ってみよう。
うっ
サポートだけお願い。
OKです。
うっ
右側によって。
どう？
右側。もっとちょいもうちょい
もうちょいもうちょい
どう？
こう？
えぇ？
まって。もう来たなこれ。
来たなこれ。
これ来た？
こんな感じ
これって感じ
これか～
これ何か役に立ちそうな？重みがある。
よし。これ買おう
ふふ
よしよしよし
なんでそんな笑うの？
あー　こっち行きます。
OKOK
OK
まて。18禁コーナー？
っふふ
あー
はっ何その反応
よし。これにしよう。
これ大丈夫？
こんな　なんですけど
え？何？
大丈夫ですよ。
それは、え～違いますね。
それ～ディスプレイです。
あ、外れちゃう外れちゃう
夜中だと人も少ないしね。
ははは　ちょっと
それいつもはじめさんがつけてる
これブラジャーじゃねえか。
これ買うわ
いまどこらへん？
マジで分かんないんだよ。
う～～
うお～～
これは高校生の男とか使うんじゃないんですか？
それはもう誰でも使うよ。
ええ？
なんだろう？
よし。これ買おう。
えっ、なんで笑う？
これ買おうぜ
これか～
これ一応商品だろう。
え？まって、そんなの
お～待って今耳になんかクラッチングスタート
クラッチングスタート？
絶対18禁コーナーでしょ。
どのへんが？
今のれんがかかったもん。
これは、ヤバイ
え～？どう言う事？
ん？こんなもんっしょ。
それではじゃあ、お会計いきますか。
まだ僕は何を買ったかというのはまだ分かっていません。
で、今からちょっと後輩が運んでもらうんですけど
はい。と言う訳でちょっと一品ずつ置いていってもらいます。
よし。頼む。
失礼します。
ま、まあまあまあ。まあまあ、まあまあじゃないっすか？
これは。これ、全然実用的だと思うんでこれはもうありです。
アリエールです。
次
失礼します。
なにこれ、なにこれ。
フェイスシェイバー
あ～これ普通に使えるじゃん。
普通に使えるやつ
普通に使えるし。やったー
眉毛剃りもぜんぜんありですね。
次
これなに？
なにこれ
スモークガラス
なにを？
車です。
はっはっは
スモークでございます。
ちょっと使えないっすね。これは
次
まあ、これはね～
っははは　っちょっとまって
これなんなの？
まず、なんだろこれは？
いや、でもナイスチョイスだと思います。
っふはは
っふぁははははははは
プロテインだったのね。
ついに3kgのプロテインでした。
俺こんなの買う予定では無かったな。
う～ん　ちょっと筋肉せっかくなんで作ろうと思います。
次
あ
これは、でもね～何か欲しかった。
これーけどデカイやつじゃねえ？
やだ～
ちょちょちょちょ
おー
待って待って
はっはっはっはー
いたい　いたい　いたい　いたい
いや危ない危ない危ない危ない
うわぁーーーー
やめてよ。え～　なにこれ？
え？海ちゃんだったの？
うぉー　ぜんぜんありだよ。
ラブライブ海未ちゃんのパズルです。
時間ないんで、また暇なときにやります。
次
これは、なんだろうな？
っふ　谷間クイーンですね。
谷間クイーンと
これは下着のパンツかな？
Tバックじゃん。
っふぁはははは
凄い皆さんTバックのパンツです。
ちょっと　履いてください。
っはははは
っふ
これは～
なんだ？
こんなの買ってたのか
これ、マジか
ちょ、開けて開けてみようこれ
マジか～
こんなの買う予定じゃなかったんだけどマジで
ガチもんじゃんこれ
ふぁあ
すげーこれでもいいやつじゃん
これあれでしょプラズマクラスターのやつでしょ？
これ普通に嬉しいやつだ。
やった。ありがとう。
いやいや
あ、俺が選んだのか。
はい。と言う訳で最後はプラズマクラスター
空気清浄機の何か凄い良いやつでした。
ドンキで物を目隠しで買うと
大体こんな物があった
ふふ
大体こんな物が今の感じでございます。
皆さんドンキ行って物を買うときは、
しっかり買う物確かめてから買いましょう！
じゃあな